POLICE ALSO SAY THEY FOUND THE
FIREARM USED IN THAT ATTACK.
>> Trace: MORE PROTESTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA OVER THE WEEKEND IN
DEFIANCE OF GOVERNOR NEWSOM’S
10:00 P.M. COVID CURFEW ORDER
THAT WENT INTO EFFECT FOR MOST
COUNTIES SATURDAY NIGHT.
OUR NEXT GUEST IS A CALIFORNIA
SHERIFF WHO SAID SHE WON’T BE
ENFORCING IT.
SHERIFF, SO GOOD OF YOU TO JOIN
US.
WE APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH.
WHY DID YOU DECIDE NOT TO
ENFORCE THE CURFEW?
>> WELL THIS IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE ACTIONS OR NON-ACTIONS
WE’VE TAKEN SINCE THE BEGINNING.
I DON’T BELIEVE THIS IS A LAW
ENFORCEMENT ISSUE.
WE ARE SO BUSY ENFORCING AND
KEEPING OUR CITIZENS SAFE BY
ARRESTING ROBBERS AND CHILD
MOLESTERS AND HOME BURGLARS.
MAKING CRIMINALS OUT OF
NORMALLY LAW ABIDING CITIZENS
DOESN’T MAKE SENSE.
>> Trace: WE TALKED ABOUT THE
CRIME STATS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
HAVE GONE WAY UP.
YOU WON’T CRITICIZE SOME OF
YOUR COLLEAGUES.
WE SHOULD POINT OUT THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY SHERIFF SAYS HE
WILL ENFORCE THE CURFEW.
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY SHERIFF
SAID THE FOLLOWING.
HE IS GOING TO ENFORCE IT.
WE HAVE A LOT OF OPTIONS AND
PRETTY MUCH ON THE VOLUNTARY
COMPLIANCE SIDE.
WE GET MOST OF OUR SUCCESS.
IF WE START SCRATCHING PAPER
MEANING WRITING TICKETS THERE
ARE CONSEQUENCES THAT NEED TO
FOLLOW FROM THAT AND WE DON’T
WANT TO GET TO THAT POINT.
NOT TO CRITICIZE YOUR
COLLEAGUES BUT WHAT DO YOU
THINK OF THE VARIOUS STRATEGIES
BEING IMPLEMENTED ACROSS THE
STATE?
>> WELL, I TRUST CALIFORNIANS
AND MOST ARE DOING THE RIGHT
THING WHEN IT MAKES COMMON
SENSE.
SO FOR INSTANCE WHEN THE
GOVERNOR TALKS ABOUT THIS
CURFEW BETWEEN 10:00 AT NIGHT
UNTIL 5:00 IN THE MORNING IT’S
A HEAD SCRATCHER.
IS THIS VIRUS SO SMART IT WON’T
INFECT PEOPLE IF THEY AREN’T IN
THEIR HOMES BY 9:59?
WE ALL MAKE OUR OWN DECISIONS
WHAT IS BEST FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES AND IN FACT OUR
LOCAL DISTRICT ATTORNEY SAID
SHE WON’T FILE CHARGES OR
PROSECUTE IF THEY ARE BROUGHT
TO HER.
SO IT’S CONSISTENT IN OUR
COUNTY WITH OUR JOINT EFFORTS
IN KEEPING OUR CITIZENS SAFE
AND TRUSTING OUR PEOPLE TO DO
THE RIGHT THING.
>> Trace: YOU TALK ABOUT IS THE
VIRUS SMART ENOUGH IT DOESN’T
ATTACK PEOPLE BETWEEN 10:00 AND
6:00 IN THE MORNING?
A LOT OF PEOPLE, A LOT OF
BUSINESSES WE TALK TO
ESPECIALLY RESTAURANTS AND GYMS
AND HAIR SALONS THAT SEEM TO BE
LOW HANGING FRUIT.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IS SHUTTING
DOWN OUTDOOR DINING AGAIN THIS
WEEK.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THESE
VARIOUS THINGS WHEN YOU TALK TO
THE SCIENTISTS SHERIFF AND SAY
WE DO NOT KNOW WHERE THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THESE INFECTIONS,
WHERE PEOPLE ARE CATCHING THESE
AND YET SOME OF THE SAME
BUSINESSES, SOME OF THE SAME
CURFEWS ARE TARGETING PEOPLE
AGAIN AND AGAIN.
YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> OUR BUSINESSES, MANY OF THEM
ARE NOT GOING TO SURVIVE THIS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT BIG BOX STORES
AND THEIR PROFITS AND HOW
THEY’VE GONE UP DURING THIS
PANDEMIC AND WE ARE LOSING OUR
LOCAL BUSINESSES.
THAT MEANS LOCAL JOBS.
IT IS AGAIN I’LL CALL IT A HEAD
SCRATCHER.
I BELIEVE PEOPLE WILL
VOLUNTARILY COMPLY WHEN THINGS
MAKE SENSE TO THEM.
HOWEVER, THIS LOCAL CURFEW
BETWEEN THOSE HOURS DOESN’T
MAKE SENSE.
AGAIN, WE NEED TO REALLY PUT
OUR TRUST IN PEOPLE TO DO THE
RIGHT THING AND MOST PEOPLE IN
OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES ARE.
YOU HARDLY GO ANYWHERE WHERE
YOU DON’T SEE PEOPLE WEARING A
MASK THESE DAYS.
AND I’M JUST ENCOURAGING OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES WHEN YOU ARE
IN A CROWD AND BEING EXPOSED TO
OTHER PEOPLE.
WEAR A MASK, WASH YOUR HANDS
AND SOCIAL DISTANCE.
SOME OF THESE RESTRICTIONS AND
GOVERNMENT CONTROL PROCEDURES
ARE JUST NOT MAKING SENSE TO ME.
>> Trace: AND YOU MENTIONED
HEAD SCRATCHER A COUPLE OF
TIMES.
THE MAN IN CHARGE OF THE HEAD
SCRATCHERS IS THE GOVERNOR OF
CALIFORNIA WHO SAID THIS.
WATCH.
>> DAILY CASES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE DOUBLED JUST IN
THE LAST 10 DAYS.
THIS IS SIMPLY THE FASTEST
INCREASE CALIFORNIA HAS SEEN
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THIS
PANDEMIC.
>> Trace: IT IS CERTAINLY
GETTING WORSE, SHERIFF.
IS THERE A POINT IN THIS WHERE
YOU THINK MAYBE YOU MIGHT TAKE
THE GOVERNOR’S SIDE ON SOME OF
THESE DIFFERENT CRACKDOWNS?
>> WELL AGAIN, WHEN SOMETHING
MAKES SENSE AND THEY HAVE THE
SCIENCE AND DATA TO BACK IT UP
THAT’S SOMETHING TO BE
CONSIDERED ABSOLUTELY.
WHEN IT DOESN’T MAKE SENSE,
COMMON SENSE IS REALLY WHAT
PEOPLE WILL BELIEVE.
AND SO FAR I HAVEN’T SEEN MUCH
OF THAT.
>> Trace: SHERIFF MARGARET MIMS.